make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so my microphone died in the middle
of recording this video so I had to
rerecord it which kind of sucks but what
I want to do in this video is I'm going
to talk about even classifications
versus mutant power like I've eaten
power hierarchy human power rankings and
the reason why is because people I think
often confuse these things right they
guess that our classifications to be the
mutant power hierarchy and that's not
really true um classifications always
consider to be more of an indication of
like what kind of group mutants belong
to in terms of like the history of
mutants over the course of Marvel and
then powers are just powers and what's
all about powers here in a second but in
terms of classifications this is pretty
wide and very right so for those of you
guys who have been around my channel for
a while and you have heard this this
video this explanation really I most
recently had in my video on the Eternals
bear with me for a second while I kind
of went over it for the people who were
new here but with regards to mutants um
their origin goes back to like the
Eternals and in the Celestials right the
celestial showed up on earth they
modified the genes of a handful of girly
men one group went forward as the
deviance which are basically trolls
another group went forward as the
Eternals who were more angelic and
appearance right in terms of the fact
that they they were to some degree in
world really they were they were truly
immortal to be honest and then they also
had the ability to manipulate like
cosmic energy they could fly different
things like that and so early depictions
by by mankind in terms of how they view
the Eternals is that they were basically
gods um and then you had baseline humans
now the genes as they were modified by
the Celestials regarding baseline humans
they were just sent out into the world
what we ended up finding out later on is
that the genes were modified in two ways
the first is that X genes were planted
in some of them and then in the others
their genes were simply modified in such
a way so that when the time came when
they were bestowed with powers they
wouldn't die in the process right so
that explains why Bruce Banner didn't
die when he was exposed to gamma
radiation it explains why Steve Rogers
didn't die when he was injected with the
Super Soldier Serum and blasted with
vitae raise right it explains why those
things happen and why they turned into
superheroes as opposed to just dying
from radiation sickness because the
genes as they were modified by the
Celestials limp themselves to developing
power
now in terms of following this sort of
classification order and actually kind
of go is in a pretty linear progression
right and so the earliest mutants that
we saw start to rise to prominence were
effectively externals now the question
is what are externals these are mutants
who are legitimately immortal right I
mean they're immune to like aging
they're immune to disease illness
anything that could that could cause
physical harm on their body they're
immune to all those things now it does
not mean they have a healing factor and
it does not mean they're indestructible
right immortality and indestructibility
are two distinctly different things
immortality as is explained it really
has its it's defined by Marvel Comics
it's simply just the inability to die of
old age
that's basically what immortality is so
the traditional definition
invulnerability is of course
invulnerability the inability to sustain
physical harm um for for characters like
Selene for example she's defined as an
external but not really not talk about
why here in a second but characters like
Gideon for example are now with Celine
she's a character reason why she's not
really an external is because for a
character like Gideon he'll just live
forever but I'm he was born into the
world his his mutant gene activated
probably around puberty and he basically
developed true immortality now because
he's not invulnerable his head was
chopped off by cable in the 1990s and
that's he's basically been dead ever
since and then I think he came back
recently I don't know honestly Cain was
never I'm sorry Gideon was never really
that important so I never really cared
he was in the early stories of cable but
in terms of the modern-day doesn't
really matter what was someone like
Selene she has to drain the life energy
off people in order to sustain her
essence in order to keep herself alive
so she's not really she's not truly
immortal right the same thing goes for
someone like apocalypse but apocalypse
is kind of a mixed situation right
because Selene was born ten thousand
years ago apocalypse was born five
thousand years later and he was a
character who developed immortality when
his mutant gene activated during a high
level of stress and then in turn he
later discovered celestial technology
that allowed him to modify his body even
further and then give himself virtually
every single superhuman power so you
could argue that he's an external
because he was legitimately immortal but
Marvel's never clearly defined that
right they never really come out and
said apocalypse is an external we're
just kind of left to sort of make that
decision for ourselves and then just
kind of go from there
from there you get you get into what are
called proto mutants now there were a
handful of mutants here and there that
you know kind of a smattering around the
around the world that popped up between
5,000 years ago and and probably around
seven or eight hundred years ago but
Marvel's never really defined them
rather they're just kind of like some
remains that were found somewhere and
that's basically it
mutants that Marvel's written in such a
way where they claim to have been around
since like the very beginnings of life
on Earth's like they're billions of
years old but none of those things have
ever really been confirmed by anybody
it's just a statement someone made right
so until such a time as a curator makes
the statement in terms of what class
they belong to and then the the story is
written in a way where another character
goes to investigate and then confirms it
ah then we can't really we can't really
assume it is true we just kind of have
to go with it and and make up our own
minds and what we do or do not want to
believe but in terms of anywhere between
seven to eight hundred years ago
probably around six hundred years ago
you had proto mutants and proto meetin's
were kind of a branch off from other
mutants that were popping up around
around that that point on the difference
between proto mutants and in traditional
mutants as a proto mutants almost kind
of had like a wild unchecked kind of
power right in the sense of like they
were kind of pushed to the extreme and
we didn't really know what sort of power
they would manifest and in reality we
don't really know much about them at all
all we really know is what it is a
Gabriel Shepard told us or at least you
know house character was written in
Marvel Comics innocence that he was just
one of the proto mutants who was there
pretty much all of them are wiped out in
Macedonia during the Black Plague and or
at least as being believed to be the
cause of the black plague and he's the
only one left but looking at the power
that he has we could largely assume that
most of the proto mutants during that
time had had power you know similar to
that if not almost identical right so he
has the ability to stop time in a
localized space um he has the ability to
manipulate reality on really what seems
to be a universal scale but there's no
no absolute definition of that um he can
manipulate the electromagnetic spectrum
he can fly as telepathy telekinesis he
has a huge wide array of different
powers
um different sort you know different
things have kind of argued that he was
the ideal candidate for for those
Celestials when they first started
modifying the genes of early man he's
what they were supposed to be it wasn't
until later that Marvel came back and
confirmed there was actually Franklin
Richards right because Franklin Richards
turning out the way he did he was what
the Celestials were looking for when
they started modifying
chains of man right like he was the
verification of their experiment
succeeded is essentially what it was
right like somebody on the same power
level as themselves if not maybe even a
little bit higher but following proto
mutants that's when you really go into
like the the modern day level of use
right like the modern day era of mutants
where you just kind of have different
people with different powers all over
the place I mean to me those are the
three main classifications there are
characters like homo supreme like mister
immortal who is a legitimately immortal
guy right like he'll like if he dies
he'll just be reborn in a different form
or maybe that's a forever man he'll
always end up coming back basically oh
but but the gist behind this is that in
terms of this classification of
different versions of powers and so on
and so forth
it's it's kind of a mixed bag right and
and unless a person's come you know
guaranteed to be or at least stated to
be part of a particular class you can
just kind of throw them anywhere
depending on what era they were born in
right now um where that's a little bit
murky powers to get even more of our
here and the reason why is because if we
take something like omega-level mutant
right like we take that term for the
most part that's a term that originated
in uncanny x-men number 207 a lot of
people say uncanny x-men 208 that's
actually not correct 207 is where first
originated at and in turn it was just
kind of a one-off right it was just sort
of thrown out there as a way to indicate
this mutant is really really powerful
and then we never really saw it again
until we got x-men forever and then
Grant Morrison's run on the x-men up
until that point during Chris Claremont
17-year run all you had were mutants and
some are more powerful than others and
that was basically it
um really when you get into Grant
Morrison's run that's when we started to
get a kind of hierarchy but what you
have now is if you if you go out and you
do some google searching you'll see
things like epsilon mutants and like
gamma mutants and like Delta mutants and
so on and so forth um those are really
more fan designations the three main
categories of mutants that Marvel is
actually confirmed in terms of how me
ins reside running up to the point where
hickman started riding house of X is
that you have Beta Alpha and Omega
and that's basically and then you have
Beyond Omega level and we'll talk about
how that applies to what Hickman's doing
but with regards to to beta level
mutants these are anybody whose powers
are or are able to basically impact the
world around them but not in a very big
way right not in a huge way so say for
example someone like beast right like
beasts
has enhanced strength and agility and
things like that and blue fur and he's
got a really really smart mind but his
he doesn't really possess the power to
like alter the structure of the world or
anything like that you look at somebody
like Wolverine he's got a healing factor
I mean his body just his healing just
kind of applies to him as a passive
power meaning that the power basically
runs without him having to do anything
about it and then you've got like like
you know characters like Cyclops for
example Cyclops I would say is more more
alpha just because of the power he
possesses and how dangerous it can be
but you look at someone like Cyclops
kind of moving into the Alpha level
territory here you look at someone like
Cyclops and you say he's an awful level
mutant well the questions why because he
has the his concussive blast can cut
mountains at half right so he could have
a huge impact on the world around him in
terms of like loss of life or damage
they can be sustained or stemming along
those lines it's it's it's kind of nuts
in terms of the power he possesses then
you go into Omega and Beyond Omega level
and this is where things start to get
murdered not really murky it's where
they get sort of get a little clearer
and the reason why is because Grant
Morrison did clearly define these things
and what he did is he basically said
that in omega-level mutant is a mutant
whose power can basically fundamentally
alter the structure of the world right
and then you have the Ando mega level
where you take that concept and then
apply it to the universe they can also
the structure of the universe right like
those who can manipulate matter and
energy to affect the world or the
universe itself so you look at someone
like like Bobby Drake you look at Iceman
the reason why is considered to be Omega
level is because he's a guy that
basically creates cold where you can't
really create cold cold is simply the
absence of heat and as a result of that
if heat is simply you know atoms moving
at a rapid pace then what Bobby Drake is
doing is basically slowing them down but
the issue with this is that his power
can be surpassed because of what he's
doing is is essentially slowing down the
movement of matter in order to create
cold or something like that
he's affecting the world but there's
never been an instance where we've seen
him affect the universe right so as far
as at least at this point in time he's
not beyond Omega level you look at
somebody like storm storm can affect the
weather phenomena of any world that
she's on but we've never seen her
harness the power of a cosmic storm like
a storm raging and running throughout
the universe so there's no reason to
believe that she is a beyond Omega
level mutant but then you look at
someone like Franklin Richards and
Franklin Richards can alter the universe
on I'm sorry ultra reality on a
universal scale and so because he can do
things like that that makes him beyond
Omega level his power stretches into the
universe itself and is not just confined
to his ability to affect earth um with
regards to to magneto he was a character
who was always listed as alpha level but
I always argue who is Omega level and
this gets us into Chris I'm sorry into
Jonathan Hickman's current run what
Jonathan Hickman is basically doing is
he's removing the concept of beyond
Omega level right because in reality
doesn't really make any sense it's like
one plus infinity and in terms of you
know this Omega Beyond Omega Omega level
concept what Hickman is doing is kind of
reworking everything using some of the
traditional definitions and then
combining it with his own and so as it
stands right now in Marvel and
omega-level mutant is a mutant whose
power does not have any foreseeable
upper limit and which nobody seems to be
able to surpass right now it could
simply be because nobody has a power
like that or because no one's
demonstrated a power level equal to that
person so if we say someone like Magneto
magneto is a person who can manipulate
the electromagnetic spectrum of Earth
but because of the fact that the
electromagnetic spectrum is not just
confined to earth but is also spread out
into the universe itself it's believed
that he could probably you could
possibly do that but because we haven't
seen anybody out there shy of maybe
pilars on a good day and even then it
kind of depends that's been able to
rival Magneto's ability to control the
electromagnetic spectrum as it stands
now he's a top dog and so as a result of
that he's an omega-level mutant now in
terms of the other thing Hickman's doing
is he's moving the Omegan level
classification away from the person and
applying it to the power that was
someone like magneto he's only got one
power that's it so you would call him an
omega-level mutant but with somebody
like Jean Grey as Hickman told us she's
an Omega level telepath and the reason
why is because she has telepathy and she
has telekinesis
but her - her telekinesis is not
powerful enough to like move the earth
to the other side of the Sun it's not
powerful enough to like move the Sun out
of out of the Milky Way
I'm sorry out of the the current solar
system and in select the you know it's
like another solar system next to us
she's not powerful enough to do that
with her telekinesis hurt
with you on the other hand is powerful
enough to influence the entire world and
if she's possessed by the power of the
Phoenix force is enough to influence the
entire universe and so because of that
there really there doesn't you know with
her Hotel telepathy being what it is no
one's as powerful as she is in terms of
their telepathy right like Emma Frost is
not more powerful than she is Professor
X is not more powerful than she is she's
the most powerful telepath on earth as
it stands right now and so because her
power has not been surpassed
she's an omega-level telepath and not an
omega-level telekinetic and not an
omega-level mutant but you look at
somebody like Emma Frost she's got her
diamond form and it's a form she really
ever uses but because she has two powers
she's got her diamond form and her
telepathy you would call her an
omega-level telepath so again that's
that's that's kind of where things stand
right now but the one thing to bear in
mind is that these are always subject to
change and that's one of the big reasons
why these various mutant power levels
right like gamma and and epsilon and
Delta and and beta and alpha and omega
and Beyond Omega level it's one of the
reasons why there's so much debate among
fans is because you have writers who
contradict other writers you've got
editors who contradict other editors
you've got all kinds of things right
like a person will create a standard
it'll run that way for five years and
then a new writer will take over and
they'll just ignore everything that
happened before and create a new
standard and the question is which
standard do you go with so that's that's
why things get kind of murky when it
when it comes to this whole concept so I
imagine debates will reign supreme down
in the comment section it's really kind
of the way these things work I mean is
this you know I always saw it this way
so this Way's right I always saw it that
way that ways right um but again
Hickman's kind of reworking all that and
he's kind of giving us a new definition
for how all this stuff functions but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end hopefully
this clears things up a little bit and
and if you guys have questions about the
about like mutants in Marvel Comics post
them down in the comment section and and
I'll go over them and I'll make sense of
it and in make videos like that right
because with what Hickman's doing with
the x-men the fact that is kind of a
reboot more or less really not really a
reboot so much is like a rework but
because of what he's doing I imagine
there'll be a lot of questions out there
in terms of how mutants work how they
function different things like that
ah but yeah with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
that will catch you all later loose
[Applause]